EVREN ERYUREK: Hello everyone.
Welcome to our session
on data governance.
As some of you may remember,
back in November in London
we had announced
our partnership,
and today I'm delighted
to be with Jim again
to talk about our
progress to date.
Let's take a look at recent
Goldman Sachs reports.
Security breaches, data loss,
legal and compliance issues
are slowing down many in
their move to public clouds.
Fundamentally they're worried
about loss of control.
When you look at BigQuery it was
designed as a cloud data data
warehouse.
It was designed to address
the needs of data driven
organization in a
cloud first world
with its reliability,
security, and its governance.
So what is data governance
and why it matters?
Data governance is
a strategic part
of an organization that sets in
place policies and procedures
to maximize utilization and
value of data for decisions
and operations, while
ensuring that equality
standards, privacy
standards, security controls,
and regulatory compliance.
GCP provides robust
tools and technology
to protect and govern throughout
the lifecycle of the data.
We offer built-in
protection at scale
by default. Data is
automatically encrypted while
in transit and at rest.
We supply tools and technology
to efficiently govern
all your data.
For example Cloud DLP helps
you discover and classify
sensitive data assets.
Cloud IAM provides access
control and visibility,
security policies and our
newly G8 Cloud Data catalog
helps you discover and
manage all your data.
We support compliance
requirements
with all third-party
certifications.
Finally, we believe
that the trust
is created through transparency,
and for that we provide tools
like Access Transparency
which gives you the visibility
and accesses by
either the support
teams or the engineering
teams at all times.
Let's talk about some
of the enhancements
that we've done
around data classes
and fine-grained access.
Now with BigQuery's
column level control
you can start thinking about
data as a set of data classes,
some more sensitive than others.
Data catalog will control
policies per data class.
Audit logs will refer
to these data classes.
Let's take a look at a deeper
level and the use case.
Use data catalog to define
a taxonomy of policy attacks
and add access
permissions for users,
groups apply these policy
tags to BigQuery columns.
In this example, you may
have first responders.
They may need to have access
to some of the PII information
like location and
phone and so forth.
On the other hand, auditors
would have additional access
to maybe financial information.
Now you'll be able to provide
all these controls very easily.
On GCP we provide a platform
that's end-to-end governed.
You can imagine
almost like two zones.
A free zone where not
much of the sensitive data
is really present.
But a governed zone where a
lot of your governed data needs
are placed.
Past couple of
years, we have been
focusing on building the best
in class capabilities for you
to achieve better governed
zone through BigQuery for all
your enterprise
needs, by establishing
fine-grained access
like column, table,
role levels, and whatever.
By integrating DLP to drive
all data classification.
By introducing Data Catalog
to discover and tag your data.
However, data governance is
a vast space and many of you
have complex hybrid
environments.
As we announced last
November in London
we have partnered with
Collibra, the market
leading governance
solutions provider
to help you with all
your data governance
needs in this hybrid world.
And I'm delighted
to inform everyone
that Collibra is now GA on GCP.
And we're working
together on joint roadmaps
to further enhance our
offerings to everyone.
As we saw before Data
Catalog and BigQuery allows
you to govern data the finer
granularity through policy tax.
But governance is
much more than that.
We also need to apply,
revoke, modify access
in response to events
across your enterprise.
As I mentioned
earlier, we've already
begun integrating Collibra
into GCP services.
Our catalogs are
designed to work together
to help system
integrate achieve data
governance for hybrid
systems, whether it's
your multi-client needs
or cloud and on premise.
With Collibra on GCP you will
have the best of the two worlds
to achieve all
your data analytics
and data governance needs.
My partner Jim will now
walk you through Collibra
on GCP journey.
JIM CUSHMAN: That's great.
Thank you, Evren.
I really appreciate
the introduction.
And excited to share
with you guys a use case.
Now there's basically
countless ways
that you can identify value
from this combined offering,
but we're going to settle in on
a use case defined by George.
He's a business analyst
working on the Google Analytics
platform and he has a goal.
His goal is customer
satisfaction.
Now that's a year-long
endeavor, but over the year
he's looking for
different data sets
that answer different
questions that
show how customer satisfaction
is achieved, maintained,
it grows, and it reduces churn.
So in this situation,
we're going
to focus on a moment
in time where George
is looking for additional data
beyond what George is working
with thus far to answer some
questions about customer churn.
The process is going to
follow something like this
and it's going to be
a use case run-- what
we call data provisioning.
This is a situation where
there's only a subset of data
that George currently has access
to, but looking for what else
might be available to use.
So George will start
with an example
of using Collibra to actually
work on the Google Cloud
to search the catalog.
And once that's done our job
is to help navigate George
through the shopping experience,
go out and fetch the data
for George, and present it
back to George for consumption.
So let's go ahead and jump in.
So let's suppose George
starts-- the first thing
that George is going to do
using this shopping metaphor is
try to find a door to open.
And so George being kind
of a non-technical person
might start with more
of a business term.
So George is going to
type in "customer churn".
And customer churn for
George is a definition that's
been defined in his
business glossary
and is shared within
the entire company.
Now when George
first sees this he
can then navigate to
different facts and facets
such as picking business terms,
and these business terms then
provide various things
within the glossary
that George can choose from.
If George chooses
customer churn it
takes George to the next step.
Now this is like
opening up a door
to our graph of information
available to George.
And some of the things
that George might see
is which models are actually
available underneath
the definition of
customer churn,
such as customer
order or product.
Some financial metrics,
tags, and other things.
And this is a means
of George basically
getting oriented
within the store
and finding out
where to go to next.
And let's suppose
George says customer
is a really important
thing, but I'd
like to know a little
bit more about it.
So one of the first
things we do is
show George what is the content
of customer as a logical model.
And here we're listing all
of the different attributes
and fields that really
make up the definition
of the canonical
definition of a customer.
In any one of these George can
click on one of the definitions
and learn more about them.
Again, as an asset within the
graph that again relates up
to the customer demand model.
But again, back to customer
churn as a business term.
Now, Cliff might
say this is great.
I like the content here.
So let me learn
more, so I'm going
to navigate down the aisle.
As Cliff navigates
down the aisle
of this-- kind of
customer defined aisle--
we're going to find
various things that
are groups such as systems.
And within systems
might have databases,
and with them that
might have schemas.
And eventually you
get down to tables.
These are catalog
assets that tell
Cliff about the various
things that the company is
aware of that have been
classified and mapped
to the logical
model of customer.
And so this kind of gives you
an inventory of ultimately
what is in this file that the
shopping known by customer.
Furthermore, Cliff might
want to say OK, tell me more.
And this is where we show the
integration and the inheritance
to a table all the way back
to policies, and rules,
and regulations,
and limitations,
and reference data that make up
the body of governance that's
within the Collibra system.
So in this situation,
Cliff can see
very quickly that I had a table
within here called customer
product sales that had actually
been classified through machine
learning to the customer
domain, and by definition
then it inherits
all the items that
are classifications and
standards and policies
that you see in
green illustrated
to the left of the screen.
Once Cliff understands this,
Cliff might say, OK I like this
but I want to know where
these products have actually
come from.
Where do these tables come
from and where do they go,
and maybe what happens?
And that's what we call lineage.
This is the idea of how did
the data actually arrive
at this point in destination?
Where else does it go
after this destination?
Who uses it?
And did anything happen to
it on its destination to me,
such as some type of
transformation object?
So we can actually capture all
the underlying transformation
that may have happened
to this physical asset
that you're considering
for shopping purposes.
So this gives Cliff like a
where's this stuff made--
is it made in the US?
Is it made in Italy?
Somewhere else?
I would like to know, as well
as what happened on its journey
along the way.
Now the next thing
Cliff might say
is, OK I'm now down to
five different items
to choose on the shelf.
How do I delineate between them?
How do I know which
one is right for me?
Well that oftentimes is being
done through tribal knowledge
or what did I do in the
past, but it's generally not
objective or defendable
and doesn't always lead
to trustworthy information.
So what we offer in
the Collibra solution
are highly visible
and easy visualization
around a profile score.
And the goal is to provide Cliff
very quickly front of label
demarcation about what is
the best for what they want.
So in this situation we're
showing various attributes that
make a customer of
interest to George,
and showing which system
actually has the best.
So for example the
customer Billings
seems to have the
high score for email,
whereas customer
product sales has
the best information for both
address and for churn date.
Since those are
important it seems
like customer product sales
is something that would
be pretty important to George.
Now maybe that's not
enough front of label.
Some of us shoppers like
to turn the label around,
and if necessary we can get
some detailed statistical
information about that
column using stats
around no values,
anonymous values,
distribution
frequencies, et cetera,
that can really help Cliff
choose which of these data
sets to use for his analysis.
Now Cliff has said OK,
this is the one I want.
I'm adding customer
products sales,
as you see illustrated
in the center here.
And this is in Cliff's
shopping basket.
Now you can see there are other
data sets that were already
in there.
Let's just assume Cliff had
already shopped for things
and maybe these were
sitting in wait.
But the next big thing that
Cliff wants to do is say,
you know, I'm not just buying
product at the grocery store,
I'm actually asking for data
and I need to ask for a request.
So Cliff starts the
request process.
And each customer can
set up its own need
for how they manage
this process.
But ultimately the
data owner itself
that would grant
authorization to this data
would want to know
why do you want it?
How long are you
going to use it?
Where are you going
to use it, et cetera.
And so George enters this level
of information in the data set
request.
And one thing I'll
draw your attention to
is that George has
actually selected lease.
Lease is this notion of
a short term duration
but I want a physical
copy of the data,
whereas borrow would be an
example of something I just
want to have virtualized
for a very, very
short period of time.
And buy would be I
actually want to take
a full copy going forward.
And that ultimately
might also say,
where do I want to take it?
And here we're actually
going to bring the data set
to Google BigQuery.
And of course there
are dates for how long
George would like to use it.
Now after George has actually
submitted his request
it needs to go over
to the data owner.
So we're going to switch
perspectives really
quickly and look at Joanna, and
she receives an inbound request
from George.
And so you can see that Joanna
is seeing the same information
that George entered in in the
request in the center panel,
and off to the right is
where Joanna would then
determine whether she wants to
grant approval for this or not.
Now, I'm showing you a
manual version for this now,
obviously for effect,
but you can set up
rules and workflows that can
automate this process based
on who's making the request,
for what purpose, for how long,
and where is it going to go.
But you can either
manually do it
or you can set up
automated rules.
But since she actually
approves this request then
it's going to go back to George.
And when it comes back to
George there's one last thing
that he has to do.
He has to acknowledge
all of the items
to the right that are part
and parcel of actually
taking a lease of data
for a period of time
to Google BigQuery.
And you'll remember
those were established
in those green boxes earlier on
when we looked at the customer
domain.
And they were all
inherited through
to the data set that
George is now asking for.
So once George has actually
approved of this request
he can now check out.
And so this the really
interesting part, because again
George is not a technician.
We don't want
George to have to do
a bunch of assembly, et cetera.
We're now going to kick off
a data provisioning process.
And so we really are finished
up with step one here.
And then the next step
is that we're actually
going to have an
edge-based appliance.
It really is close
to the data center,
wherever it happens to be.
Suppose it's on
your own premise.
It could be in another cloud.
It could be a
SaaS-based solution
that you're working with.
It is this virtual appliance
that actually is reading back
to the Google Cloud server
to talk to the bigger cloud
and say, do I have
any instructions?
And the instructions
would be this request
that George has asked for
and received approval.
They would be
downloaded and they
would execute a
distributed query
against the underlying
data set or data sets that
have been approved.
After that data is extracted
it would then be composited,
which is basically
the process of looking
for any duplication
within that data set
and compositing it
down to a golden record
choosing the best attributes
from amongst the contributors.
Once that's been
done then we also
want to acknowledge that
not all Georges are alike.
Some Georges might have access
to certain data elements
that others are not.
And that's where we deploy
this policy enforcement
around access management.
We would actually eliminate
data that's not actually
available for George to
look at, either by redacting
it or masking it before it's
passed along to be loaded
into BigQuery for the request.
Once that's done the
data is then encrypted,
transformed up to the
appropriate landing
spot for BigQuery, and
then subsequently loaded
into BigQuery.
And once that's
been done now George
is notified that the data
set is ready for processing.
Now when the data is ready
for processing George
can do a couple of things.
He can look at the data in the
raw directly within BigQuery.
But more likely George
is going to want
to look at this and VI reporting
or analytic environment
of choice, and let's
suppose it's Looker.
And so that's
exactly how George is
going to start working
with this new data set
and maybe either alone or in
combination with other data
sets that were already available
to George within BigQuery
as well as Google Catalog, or
in combination or separately.
So now George has
actually been--
almost really at the
click of a button--
had data provision for
his use without having
to write any code.
And it's all been done
under a governed use case.
And so that's really what we
call data use provisioning.
But to really round
out the use case
we have to send notification and
reminder to George that you're
just using this data for
a short period of time.
In order to comply with
the data use agreement
you actually have to get rid
of it when you're done with it.
So we send a notice
off to George
to let him know exactly
that your use of the data
has expired and it's
time to get rid of it.
And of course then
we'll notify Joanna
if the same has occurred.
If in fact, it's been compliant
and George did get rid of it.
Otherwise, it
would get escalated
and she would be able to follow
up accordingly to make sure
that we stay in compliance.
Now this is just one of many,
many use cases to follow.
We thought it was a
good illustration of how
the combined solution
works together
in a highly relevant use case.
In terms of where
we are today, Evren
was kind enough to announce
that we're available on Google
Cloud as of July 6th.
Now we are also working on more
and more tighter integration
and you'll see where we are now.
We're at storage with
"principle of least privilege"
with data class level securities
available within Google.
And through the
integration with Collibra
we also offer this ability
to shop and discover and make
that request for data.
And it could be data that's
already in BigQuery or in cloud
storage that they're
just asking for approval,
or it might actually
need to be provisioned.
In situations where it actually
needs to be provisioned
we'll be covering that within
the next year's roadmap.
But I think I'd also like to
share with you that later this
year-- maybe by the
end of the year--
Collibra Data Intelligence
for your convenience
will be available on
the Google Marketplace.
And if you've enjoyed what
you've listened to here
I really highly recommend that
you follow your other peers
in the industry.
Even though we've just announced
this a short period of time ago
we have a large
number of customers
who've already
expressed interest
and are starting
that journey with us.
So if you would like to follow
in their footsteps, please,
I would suggest you follow
up either at the Google Cloud
website or the Collibra website.
On behalf of Evren
and myself I would
like to thank you
for joining us,
as well as wish you guys safety
in these difficult times.
Thank you.